foi bom
south ferraz o artista grafiteiro e não
sou palestrante então vamos lá
quando me convidaram pra excited x eu
falei cara quando eu descobrir a cura de
uma doença ou quando foi campeã em
tecnologia que mudou a revolucionou a
revolucionar a humanidade
bom não fiz nenhum desses mas eu vou
trazer à reflexão
começando com uma pergunta o que é a
arte pra você e não um significado da
arte e sim o que ela representa na vida
de cada um
pra isso eu vou falar um pouco da minha
história e como a arte me impactou em
diversos momentos da minha vida cabeça o
dinho aí sou eu
no começo da minha vida que eu tive o
privilégio de ter pais que sempre me
incentivavam a ver filmes sem mostrar um
livro sempre levar mais posições mostrar
uma referência de arte e arquitetura e
sempre me incentivaram muito teve uma
situação um que minha mãe me levou para
um passe um filme eu e meu irmão criança
ainda é óbvio que ela não levou um filme
de hollywood o último lançamento de
hollywood
ela me levou para um cinema lado b para
ver um filme de drama marroquino e
provavelmente ela não leu a sinopse diz
levar gente com tanto que já estou
entrando e esse sou eu sair ainda nesse
momento a arte impactou de uma forma que
me chocou e que é uma das funções da
arte ela mostrar outro ponto de vista o
crescimento e se tranquilo e esse é isso
eu durante a escola que sempre foi
aquela criança que desenhava vida todo
incentivo que recebi tudo que eu
tudo que eu vi eu era criança que
desejava na mesa criança que não anotava
muito trabalhoso e sim ficava desenhando
no caderno
isso fazia com que os diretores me
chamou para fazer o convite da festa
junina o fundo de palco do teatro e o
que precisasse
após um tempo eu com 18 anos
a representação que diz muito sobre
quando tinha 18 anos ea arte sempre
esteve presente comigo até então eu fiz
uma coisa que muitos jovens muita gente
nessa idade faz
tive uma filha minha filha tem 14 anos a
mel linda hoje em dia e e que aconteceu
o que isso tem a ver com a arte
aconteceu que eu tive um choque de
realidade bem cedo
eu tinha 18 anos tá precisando nesse
momento gerar dinheiro e ainda queria
trabalhar com arte
nessa equação eu cheguei no seguinte
casa
eu queria trabalhar com arte e precisava
de dinheiro
o resultado já começa com mais ou menos
né porque o resultado não ia ser fácil e
imediato ainda que o que eu fiz foi
então fazer um curso de design e entrar
numa agência entrar na agência consigo
olhar hoje para trás e ver que foi uma
coisa que eu aprendi muito e eu convivi
com pessoas extremamente talentosas
pessoas que me ensinaram muito
mas pode ver que a arte está andando em
paralelo em um pouco distante
eu fiz isso acho que durante o tempo da
faculdade mas o tempo deve ter dado uns
oito anos teve um dia que eu falei meu
uma idéia brilhante
eu não vou trabalhar pra ninguém vou
trabalhar pra mim me juntei com o sócio
e montei minha própria agência foi foram
os dois anos que eu mais info dia e que
a arte ficou mais distante da minha vida
eu me vi como um pagador de conta e
encara como um bom crescer nos momentos
de crise a gente pode superar
eu falei cara precisa trazer essa arte
novo pra mim fiz alguns contatos e
cheguei tive uma resposta do marketing
de uma grande rede de lojas
de roupa e eles falaram tá bom o título
em pintar que um portão da nossa loja
que os portões de metal
fui lá me esforcei fiz o melhor trabalho
com o cobom
sem falsa modéstia ficou bom
eu fiz o primeiro diz adorar um filho
segundo adoraram filho terceirizadora
hram eu falei
daí eles chegaram com a seguinte
proposta para a gente quer crescer 20 e
os 40 lojas em pó
coisa linda né afinal a o portão de aço
tem uma especificidade que dessas lojas
ele estava abaixado quando a loja está
fechada está levantado quando a loja
está aberta ou seja pintava de madrugada
da meia noite às nove da manhã eu estava
pintando das 9 até a meia-noite como
todo mundo sabe está na agência
eu tava lá dá conta fechava falei pô
beleza
só que eu esqueci que nesse meio do
caminho ela dormir também logo a conta
não fechou e eu tive que teve um momento
dessa vida da minha vida que eu
considero muito importante que foi um
momento de quebra onde eu saí do emprego
tem algumas mil aspas lac no tradicional
pra seguir a carreira artística
eu tive uma conversa muito amistosa com
o meu sócio e que a gente se separou e
aí eu pude falar oficialmente um artista
acontece que no mundo real é um artista
do mundo real e daí sou o artista do
mundo real desesperado com spray na mão
quem sabe muito o que fazer com as
questões ainda dinheiro que é acho que é
uma questão que não só na arte é uma
coisa que vai perseguir sempre o
reconhecimento e estilo próprio do
artista
e é desse estilo próprio que eu vou
falar um pouco que é o que vai
desencadear um projeto que eu quero
falar para vocês que vou mostrar o meu
estilo próprio ele é muito focado em
retrato meu trabalho é um retrato e
começou em viagens eu ia pra praia
probar desenhar um amigo desenhavam um
professor desenhavam um cara que tinha
acabado de conhecer uma indiazinha da
praia e eu passar isso para a tela e eu
sentia que ficava vazio falar cara eu
tinha uma [ __ ] troca pessoa e quando
passava pra tela ficava um rosto que não
mostrava nada da história nada daquela
troca incrível que a gente tinha tido
evoluindo coloquei uma letra do lado uma
frase colocavam pensamento alguma
reflexão que eu tinha eu cheguei nesse
resultado que é um trabalho que estou
fazendo hoje em dia que o conceito é que
por trás de cada retrato tem uma
história onde tem o rosto da pessoa e
essa parte escrita que são as tags umas
gerações mas letras está falando muito
da história inclusive no final tem
aquele que na princesinha do lado do
indiozinho quem quiser pegar depois pode
pegar manter nada do que estou falando
eu fiz a maya eu fiz a raquel fiz amarem
a dona julieta tudo baseado nisso como
se eu pudesse congelar aquele momento a
eternidade amar e nunca vai ter a
história que ela teve até esse momento
nunca vai ter o sonho que ela teve esse
momento porque amanhã já vai ser onde
vai ser outra pessoa
minha pretensão era isso congelar aquele
instante para sempre foi evoluindo um
pouco meu trabalho eu percebi que não
necessariamente precisa fazer a pessoa e
sim eu podia fazer congelar um como se
fosse um símbolo e se no caso para ficar
mais mas claro eu fiz uma prova em
comenda de um casal de advogados que
trabalha com causas de criança sempre
bem em busca de igualdade
isso aqui foi um outro caso onde um
casal tem um filho a de filho de forma
biológica não conseguiu resolveu adotar
e não é a filha é simplesmente um
símbolo e é onde eu chego no projeto que
eu quero mostrar pra vocês que é o mundo
da arte que mostra um inesperado quando
eu não estava percebendo não estava
esperando eu recebi uma ligação de uma
de uma professora que enfim uma coisa
que eu não esperava que trouxe isso para
mim é um vizinho que é auto explicativo
não é muito usual mas
acho que a melhor forma de explicar
metido ferrara e eu acredito que atrás
de cada retrato tem uma história a
história tem um sonho e é isso que eu
tento resgatar o meu trabalho
eu estava em casa e recebi uma mensagem
e era de uma professora de um colégio
público falando que queria que o
pintasse uma sala do isso ficou na minha
cabeça tudo que eu fui visitar a escola
no mesmo dia quem sabe aí
chegando lá e conhecer a professora eles
lá explicou toda a situação do colégio
os alunos professoras e eu vi que eu
poderia fazer
fazer mais com a parede
eles tiveram aula de arte mais focado em
um ataque na diagonal e pinta uma tela
os alunos
eles acompanharam o processo e também os
mocinhos
essa oficina fã está francamente mais
legais que eu passei melhor tempo dos
alunos professores e consegui entender
mais sobre isso universo onde colocou o
aluno de pedir pro outro e através de
perguntas mais muito feliz
conseguimos cumprir por macho da vida e
história e som anos do aluno da fama
chega com o resultado o resultado foi
muito legal eu aprendi muito sobre o
torcedor a se inspirar na boca
que nessa escola eu vi que um dos
professores eles possam
eu sou filho de professor uma típica
dessa vivência pra ver o real poder
importância pela escola eo professor tem
se transformado em livro
na verdade é só uma aluna
serys e principalmente na cidade como se
fosse uma folha em branco
você pode desenhar pior coisa o melhor
nessa última o privilégio do mercado
como dança a vida e é isso que o
desmentiu
[Música]
bom foi esse projeto que eu fiz na nessa
escola na na base do pico do jaraguá e
depois desse projeto e até foi tenho até
pro o convidado para ir para a áfrica
mais especificamente em luanda angola
fez um projeto muito parecido também
igualmente foi incrível e só depois de
logo depois de tudo isso eu percebi que
o o o intenção nesse projeto foi que
promoção trará para ocupar as crianças o
que eu tive lá atrás que foi um caminho
eu mostrei que sem pretensão de
transformar nenhum daqueles alunos em
artistas ou qualquer coisa do gênero mas
mostrar uma referência mostrar que
existe arte que tem como viver de arte e
que existe um caminho diferente do que
estão acostumados a ver no dia a dia
dando aquele moleque cabeça o dinheiro
que recebeu todas as informações dos
pais que foi no cinema marroquino que
foi fazer o convite das deficiências e
daí eu volto à pergunta inicial que é o
que a arte pra você
obviamente cada um vai ter sua leitura
de acordo com que recebeu de informação
sobre a arte de como a arte impactou de
como a arte agrediu ou não mas o que eu
posso falar o que a arte é pra mim que a
arte pra mim é o meu dia a dia é meu
sustento e eu pude ver com esse projeto
que a arte também pode ser um
instrumento de mudança
é isso aí obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]